he tenido todas las oportunidades que ella nunca tuvo,
y esto ha hecho que mi historia sea muy diferente.
En lugar de huir de las grandes instituciones,
he corrido hacia ellas.
He tenido la oportunidad a lo largo de mi carrera
de trabajar para el Wall Street Journal, la Casa Blanca
y ahora una de las instituciones financieras más grandes del mundo,
donde dirijo inversiones sostenibles.
Estas instituciones son como cisternas,
y al trabajar dentro de ellas,
he visto la secuela tan grande que pueden dejar,
y me he convencido
que la institución de los mercados de capital global,
los casi USD 290 billones en reservas y bonos en el mundo,
pueden ser una de nuestras fuerzas más poderosas
para un cambio social positivo a nuestra disposición,
si se lo pedimos.
Sé lo que algunos de Uds. están pensando,
mercados de capital global, cambio social positivo,
no van generalmente en la misma frase o ni siquiera en el mismo párrafo.
Creo que mucha gente piensa que los mercados de capital son como un océano.
Es un fuerza natural indiferente, impersonal, amplia,
a la que nuestros deseos o necesidades no le afectan.
Lo mejor que nuestras pequeñas cuentas de ahorros
o cuentas de retiro pueden hacer
es tratar de agarrar algunas olas en los ciclos buenos
y tener la esperanza de no inundarse en los turbulentos,
por supuesto, nuestras decisiones de cómo guiar nuestras pequeñas cuentas de retiro
no afectan la corriente,
no cambian la forma o el tamaño o la dirección de las olas.
¿Por qué es eso?
Porque en realidad, un tercio de este océano de capital
pertenece a individuos como nosotros,
y la mayoría del resto de los mercados de capital
es controlado por las instituciones que obtienen su poder y autoridad
y su capital de nosotros,
como miembros, participantes, beneficiarios, accionistas o ciudadanos.
Entonces, si somos los propietarios reales de los mercados de capital,
¿por qué no podemos hacer que escuchen nuestras voces?
¿Por qué no podemos hacer olas?
Déjenme preguntarles algo distinto:
¿Alguno de Uds. compró café de comercio justo
la última vez que fueron a un supermercado o a un Starbucks?
Ok. ¿Alguno de Uds. va a un restaurante
y ordena trucha de crianza sostenible
en lugar de un róbalo chileno glaseado con miso
que realmente desearían?
¿Alguno de Uds. manejan vehículos híbridos o eléctricos?
¿Por qué hacemos estas cosas?
Un auto eléctrico no importa mucho en una flota de 1200 milllones
de vehículos de motor de combustión.
Un pez es solo un pez en el mar.
Y una taza de café
no significa una colina de granos en este mundo loco.
Las hacemos porque creemos que importan,
que nuestras acciones contribuyen,
que nuestras decisiones pueden influir en otros
y qué impacto podemos tener colectivamente.
En mi bolsa tengo una taza de café que compré hace un par de años.
Es una taza reusable. Tiene todas estas cosas impresas.
Miren algunas de las cosas que tiene, que dice.
"Esta taza puede usarse una y otra vez".
"Esta taza puede inspirar a otros a usarla también".
"Esta taza ayuda a salvar el planeta".
No tenía idea que esta taza de plástico fuera tan poderosa.
(Risas)
¿Por qué creemos que nuestra elección
de un taza de café artesanal de USD 4 de comercio justo cultivada a la sombra
en un taza reusable importa,
pero lo que hacemos con USD 4000
en nuestra cuenta de inversión para nuestra pensión no cuenta?
¿Por qué no podemos decirle a los supermercados
y a los mercados de capital que nos importa,
que nos importan los estándares de trabajo justo,
que nos importan los métodos de producción sustentable
y las comunidades saludables?
¿Por qué no estamos votando con nuestros dólares de inversión,
como votamos por nuestros lattes?
Yo creo que tiene algo que ver con los mitos,
las fábulas que todos traemos en nuestra conciencia colectiva.
¿Recuerdan el cuento de Grimm acerca de la olla mágica de avena?
Si le dices a la olla "hierve, pequeña olla, hierve",
se va a llenar de avena dulce.
Si le dices "para, pequeña olla, para",
va a parar.
Pero si dices las palabras equivocadas, no nos escucharía,
y todo puede salir fatal.
Así que cuando se trata de mercados,
tenemos algo similar a esta fábula en nuestra cabeza.
Creemos que los mercados son esta olla mágica
que obedece sólo una orden:
Haz más dinero.
Sólo esas palabras dichas de esa manera
van a lograr que el cazo se llene de oro.
Añade algunas palabras extras como "protege el medio ambiente",
el encanto puede que no funcione.
Pon las palabras equivocadas como "promueve justicia social",
y quizá veas tus monedas de oro encogerse.
o hasta desvanecerse por completo, según esta fábula.
Así que le preguntamos a la gente, ¿qué piensan realmente?
Salimos y encuestamos a mil inversionistas individuales,
y encontramos algo fascinante.
Abrumadoramente,
la gente quería añadir esas palabras extras a la fórmula.
71% de la gente dijo sí,
estaban interesados en inversión sostenible,
que definimos como tomar lo mejor en proceso de inversión de clase
que ya se tiene tradicionalmente
y añadir la información extra que se tiene al pensar en el ambiente,
y la sociedad y la buena gobernación. 71% querían eso.
72% dijeron que creían que las compañías que lo hacían
iban a salir mejor financieramente.
La gente realmente piensa que a uno le va a ir bien, haciendo el bien.
Pero esto lo extraño:
54% de la gente aún dijeron
que si ponían su dinero en este tipo de bienes,
pensaban que harían menos dinero.
¿Será cierto?
¿Obtienes menos avena dulce si inviertes en café crecido a la sombra
en lugar de beberlo?
Bueno, los inversionistas en compañías como Burt's Bess
o Ben & Jerry no dirían eso. ¿Verdad?
Ambos comenzaron como compañías pequeñas, socialmente conscientes
que terminaron convirtiéndose tan populares con los consumidores
que los gigantes Unilever y Clorox las compraron
por cientos de millones de dólares.
Cada una.
Pero esto es lo importante.
Esas corporaciones se dieron cuenta de que
si querían proteger el valor de sus inversiones,
tenían que preservar la misión socialmente consciente.
Si no seguían añadiendo esas palabras extras
de respeto al medio ambiente o consciente socialmente,
esas marcas no harían más dinero.
Pero quizá esa es la excepción que confirma la regla ¿no es verdad?
Las compañías serias que fundan nuestra economía
y fundan nuestros retiros y que realmente hacen girar al mundo,
necesitan adherirse a ganar más dinero.
La escuela de negocios de Harvard investigó esto
y encontraron algo fascinante.
Si hubieran invertido un dólar hace 20 años
en un portafolio de compañías
que se enfocaban extrictamente en hacer más dinero
trimestre a trimestre,
ese dólar
hubiera crecido a UDD 14 y 46 centavos.
Eso no está mal, hasta que consideras
que si en lugar de que invirtieras ese mismo dólar
en un portafolio de compañías
que se enfocan en agrandar su negocio
y en los asuntos ambientales y sociales más importantes,
ese dólar hubiera crecido
a USD 28 y 36 centavos.
Casi el doble de avena dulce.
Ahora, aclaremos, no lo lograron superar
regalando dinero para parecer un ciudadano corporativo agradable.
Lo hicieron enfocándose en las cosas que importan para su negocio,
como gastando menos energía y agua
en sus procesos de manufacturación;
como asegurándose de que los contratos de los CEOs los incitaban a obtener
resultados a largo plazo de la compañía y las comunidades que servían,
no solo resultados trimestrales;
o construyendo una cultura de primera clase con una lealtad de empleado,
retención y productividad más alta.
Harvard no está sola,
Oxford también hizo un estudio donde examinaron 120 estudios diferentes
observando los efectos de sustentabilidad y los resultados económicos,
y encontraron, una y otra vez,
que las compañías que se preocupan por este tipo de cosas importantes
de hecho tenían una mejor eficiencia operacional,
costo de capital más bajo
y mejor ejecución en el precio de mercado.
Y también está Al Gore.
Hace 20 años, cuando trabajé para Al Gore en la Casa Blanca,
él fue uno de los pioneros que suplicaba a los negocios y los gobiernos
poner atención a los retos del cambio climático.
Posteriormente, abrió una firma de inversión llamada Generación,
donde integró sustentabilidad ambiental y otras cosas
justo en el centro del proceso de inversión.
En ese entonces había un poco de escepticismo en su punto de vista.
Diez años después, su historial es otro punto de verificación
que la inversión sustentable bien hecha puede ser una inversión sólida.
Lejos de hacer menos avena dulce
por añadir sustentabilidad a la mezcla,
en realidad superó significativamente el punto de referencia.
Ahora, inversión sustentable,
la buena noticia es que no requiere un encanto mágico
y no requiere un secreto de inversión,
y no es solamente para la elite.
No se trata solamente de capital privado para billonarios.
No se trata solo de inversiones con nombres de moda
como tecnología limpia, o microfinanciamiento en mercados emergentes
o panaderías artesanales en Brooklyn.
Se trata de acciones y bonos y las 500 compañías de Fortune.
Se trata de fondos mutuos.
Se trata de todas las cosas
que ya vemos en el mercado hoy en día.
Aquí está por lo que estoy convencida
que colectivamente tenemos el poder
de hacer de las inversiones sustentables lo común.
Para empezar, los puntos de verificación aparecen todo el tiempo
que la inversión sustentable bien hecha,
preservando todos los mismos principios buenos de inversión,
la esfera tradicional, rinde.
Tiene sentido.
Además,
el mayor obstáculo que se pone en nuestro camino
puede que esté solo en nuestra cabeza.
Solo tenemos que deshacernos de ese mito
que si le añadimos nuestros valores a nuestro pensamiento de inversión,
vamos a obtener menos avena dulce.
Una vez que eliminamos la fábula,
se pueden comenzar a apreciar los hechos de los que hemos hablado.
Por último, el futuro ya se encuentra aquí.
La inversión sustentable de hoy es un mercado de 20 billones de dólares
y es el segmento de crecimiento más rápido de la industria de inversión.
En EE. UU. ha crecido enormemente, como pueden ver.
Hoy en día representa uno de cada seis dólares
bajo la dirección profesional en EE. UU.
¿Qué estamos esperando?
Para mí, se remonta a la inspiración que recibí de mi madre.
Ella sabía que quería una vida
donde tendría la libertad de tomar sus propias decisiones
y que oyeran su voz y escribir su propia historia.
Tenía pasión por ese objetivo
y tenía claro que no iba a dejar a ningún ejército, ningún obstáculo,
o insitución grande ponerse en su camino.
Se fue a EE. UU.,
y se convirtió en maestra,
autora ganadora de premios
y madre,
que terminó mandando a sus hijas a Harvard.
En estos días, podríamos decir que está lo suficientemente cómoda
siendo el centro de atención en las instituciones más poderosas del mundo.
Parece como muy profético
que su nombre en coreano significa
"claridad apasionada".
Claridad apasionada:
por eso creo que necesitamos promover el cambio.
Pasión por el cambio que queremos ver en el mundo,
y claridad de que podemos ayudar a trazar el curso.
Tenemos más oportunidad hoy más que nunca
de tomar decisiones.
Tenemos más poder que nunca para hacer que se escuchen nuestras voces.
Cambiar la perspectiva.
Voten con su cambio pequeño.
Inviertan en el cambio que quieren ver en el mundo.
Cambien las fábulas
y cambien los mercados.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)